hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from defeated World rapid
Championship I mentioned that I will be
returning to this one once we uh ended
the the three days of Rapid in two days
of Blitz it is a game from the final
round of defeated World rapid
Championship uh in between Maxima
shelagrav and Vincent kaimer now uh
going into the final round three players
were tied for first place with nine
points uh vladislavartame Vincent kaimer
and the Magnus Carlsen were tied for
first place which means that anyone can
still take it uh Artemis has lost the
Fabiano caruana in the final round so he
is definitely out of the race and the
Magnus already finished his game he
defeated
it was an incredible game and uh well
now it's uh all depends on uh the game
Vincent vs Maxine and as Magnus finished
his game uh he of course went to this
board and Magnus was watching it for the
better part of the game as he finished
his game much much sooner so let's check
it out and let's see how the game went
as it's it's for a rapid it's an
extremely top level game you guys will
enjoy it and then let's see what happens
so Maxime with the white pieces opens
with E4 we have E5 by uh Vincent Knight
to F3 Knights the C6 and Bishop to B5
and Maxime goes for the rui Lopez A6
morphe's defense Bishop to A4 and now
Knight to F6 we have Bishop sorry we
have castles uh Bishop to E7 and now D3
we have B5 Bishop to B3 and D6 so this
is very very standard stuff uh Ponta A3
and now Knight the A5 going after that
Bishop on B3 Bishop to A2
and of course Pawn to C5 we have Knight
to C3 Bishop to E6 and now Bishop to G5
so this is a top level Theory uh
something you would expect out of a
classical game we have Castles by
Vincent and now the top move here is
Bishop characters and F6 Maxine mixes it
up a little bit he plays Spawn to B4
which I believe is might be even
stronger but who knows we have Knight
backed the C6 and now Knight the D5
Maxim keeps the light Square Bishop
alive as the light Square Bishop is the
favorite one in the Roy Lopez and here
you have to be careful like you you you
might consider Knight captures on D5 but
this would maybe give white a bit too
much after he captures on D5 both of
your pieces are hanging and then let's
say Bishop captures D captures an E6 F
captures Bishop captures and now of
course King the h8 and the B captures on
C5 so you will get a position uh that's
uh pretty pretty wild uh black would
have the open semi-open file for the
attack but the problem problem is let's
say a41 Mesa black spawn structure here
and the white keeps this monster Bishop
for the rest of the game and from
experience you know that this could not
uh well probably will not end well for
black so instead Bishop captures on D5
by Max Team Sorry by Vincent uh e
characters on D5 and now Knight to D4
offering a trade of knights B captures
and C5 Knight captures and F3 and ice
fishing sug Queen captures and only now
the captures on C5 and now as you can
see Maxim does have a pass d-pawn but
Vincent does have the a b and c pawn and
he will uh push them to try and create a
pass Pawn of his own now the known moves
here are Rook after E1 and yes we are
still in theory rook fte1 and Rook a to
E1 are known moves which uh put directly
puts pressure on the E5 Pawn but Maxine
went A4 right away and it is now as of
move 17 that we have a completely new
game so it's a move that you always play
when black has this very nice expansion
on the queen side uh to uh to mess it up
yeah and now uh Vincent goes Knight back
to E8 he offers the trade a trade of uh
dark Square Bishops and he wants to
reposition tonight uh to D6 so Bishop
captures with Queen captures eight
Caprice and B5 a capture Sun B5 uh but
now the problem is those Rook a rookie
one move that we were discussing do not
come with Tempo the queen is already an
E7 guarding the pawn so Queen to E3
putting pressure on both of them and
just Knight back to F6 we have Bishop to
B3 offering a trade of Rooks and now
Queen to D6 blockading the D5 pawn and
also putting pressure to it Rook capture
78 Rook captures and now Rook to E1
going after the E5 Pawn Zone sort of
offering a trade here but Rook back to
EA the Vincent just defends it and now
Pawn to C4 now Maxine would very much
like it if um uh if Vincent would trade
here this would give him a connected
pass pawn and he could shift the bishop
to another diagonal uh where each where
it will be more useful but of course an
instant said nope just Pawn to B4 and
now both Maxim and Vincent have a nice
past Pawn we have F4 very nicely played
by Maxim the absolute strongest move uh
and it seems like you might be able to
capture but uh of course Queen capture
Sunny 8 will be too deadly uh just
characters captures and captures and
okay it's not Checkmate but once you
trade a maxim would be
bishop and of course completely winning
so after F4 we have pawned the E4 uh now
saying okay uh how do you deal with this
and Bishop to C2 now with the idea of
just capturing here but now comes Pawn
to G5 and G5 is a monster move by
Vincent freeing up the G7 Square for the
king and now uh this definitely is a
threat you don't care about Queen
capture 78 anymore because you don't
have to worry about Checkmate and you
will not have to give back your queen
with Queen to f8 so D captures on e4
Maxine grabs the full Center G captures
an F4 and now uh if you play Queen to F3
or if you move the queen somewhere else
Vincent will put his Queen on E5 this
will completely lock the pawns and light
squares the Maxine would have a light
Square Bishop this would just be
terrible terrible for him uh Vincent
would have all the time in the world the
setup his pieces in whatever way he
wants so instead Maxim goes for E5 right
away and now we have a trade F captures
on E3 e captures on D6 and now Rook the
A8 very nicely played and now what's the
idea here is this E3 Pawn really up for
grabs well if you capture the pawn on E3
then you get Rook to A1 with check King
F2 and Knight the G4 four king the king
and the Rook so of course you can't play
that Bishop to F5 now guards the G4
square and also puts pressure on D7 so
D7 can now be played and here Vincent
plays uh something incredible Knight
back to E8 so uh for the second time
Vincent uh properly moves his Knight
backwards uh and now Pawn to D7 Knight
back to D6 and here Rook captures an E3
and you have to be very careful you
can't really go after the bishop if you
capture the bishop then just Rook d8
check and black resigns you either win
The Rook or you get a queen into the
game or both so instead after Rook
captures on E3 Vincent goes King to f8
uh Bishop back to D3 now guards the C4
pawn and Rook to d8 you have to
eliminate this Pawn before doing
anything else Rook the H3 going for the
H7 pawn and now Rook captures on D7 we
have Road counters on H7 and now Rook
the A7 now the Knight on D6 is much much
stronger than the bishop on D3 even
though it's a nice Bishop uh it's uh
currently being it's currently stuck
guarding the C4 Pawn so this is uh
pretty bad we have Rook h8 King E7 and
now King to F2 maxim of course would uh
would love to uh trade um places of this
King and Bishop and he would now start
to uh enjoy starting he would enjoy
starting to advance his past H1 to
Victory so Rook the A2 check and now
Maxine plays King to E3 which is uh
definitely the correct idea if you play
King F3 and you try to keep an eye on
the G2 Pawn then the bishop is
undefended now Rook the D2 can be played
and let's say Bishop to F1 now you go
after the C E4 pawn and Knight captures
on C4 is a problem and if Bishop to D3
attacking The Rook Rook C3 King E2 and
now again you will capture on C4 giving
Vincent the two connected past pawns and
this is very much winning for black so
Maxime does the correct Choice he goes
for King to E3 Rook captures on G2 and
now H4 he gives up a little bit of
material to start advancing his pass
Pawn a little bit faster King Rook the
G3 check King to E2 and now Rook to H3
Vincent puts his uh Rook behind the pass
Pawn instead of this you could also
consider a nice King FC King E5 King D4
maneuver but this is also perfectly fine
we have H5 Pawn to B3 now we have rooked
the B8 Maxim has to put his Rook behind
the pass pawn and now Pawn the B2
showing that the pawn cannot be captured
because of Rook H2 check winning The
Rook so here instead we have King to D2
now comes Rook captures an H5 Rook
captures on B2 and Rook to H2 check uh
Vincent properly assesses the position
that the the Knight against the bishop
end game will be winning for him King C3
Rook captures on B2 King captures and
now King to F6 the light Square Bishop
here is much much uh worse than the
Knight the the Knight always has this
tension against the C4 pawn and the
bishop poor Bishop is stuck defending it
and the C5 Pawn is on a dark Square so
the light Square Bishop really has no
targets we have King to C3 King to E5
and now King to D2 We have King to D4
and now King to E2 offering the uh the
C4 Pawn but Vincent plays it uh properly
he advances the pawn to F5 we have King
to D2 and now uh upon the F4 King to E2
F3 with check now of course King
captains runs into King captures on D3
and white resigns so here after F3 with
check uh King the D2 was played and now
you have this position and you really
have to enjoy what winning rate position
it is
there is a not one move there is more
than one move that is winning for
Vincent uh so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this idea
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations and always uh
thinking about that night and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
uh the winning idea here is literally
any move with the Knight back Knight B7
or knight uh C8 or Knight to E8 or
Knight to F7 basically you just want to
waste a move once you waste a move the
position is completely winning for you
now the way you figure this out is that
if you win the E4 square with your king
or if you win the E3 square with your
king you win the game because then you
can uh go go behind you you can put your
king lights and G2 and you can advance
this Pawn to Victory uh now the problem
is white would be without a move let's
say you play Knight F7 here uh how can
white react you can't really move the
bishop somewhere along this diagonal
because you lose the C4 Pawn so of
course you're gonna play Bishop to F1
now uh by moving the bishop here you win
the E4 Square for your king or you don't
have to play this you could move the
king but then where do you move the king
to C2 that's just weird then you give of
the E3 square and then of course it's
completely winning so best is Bishop to
F1 now you win this E4 Square for your
king once the bishop returns King to F4
and now after Bishop to F1 you bring the
Knight back into the game Bishop to D3
Now Pawn to F2 is a completely different
story King to e two you're gonna play
King to G3 nothing white can do about
this King to F1 now King to F3 the white
king is completely boxed in and there is
no uh good move here Bishop P2 check
will be met with King to E3 and now
there are no moves if you move the king
you lose the bishop if you move the
bishop you again lose the bishop if you
move the bishop somewhere else you lose
the C4 Pawn uh the C4 pawn and one last
trick you could try is uh let's say
Bishop to F3 sort of trying to achieve
stalemate but of course Vincent would
not do this he would capture on C4
create another pass Pawn the D6 square
is guarded and easily win the game but
as they were both very low on time
Vincent Advanced the want the F2 right
away if you played Pawn to F2 and now it
seems okay it seems like it doesn't
really do all that much for why if if
King E2 then you can just bring a Queen
into the game and win the bishop but
Maxim shows that now it is a it is just
a dead draw Bishop to F1 you know even
though you win the C4 Pawn there are no
ways for you to win the game Knight
captures and C4 King to E2 now comes
King characters on D5 and now King
captures an F2 and there is no way for
black to cross the C4 square with the
Pawn King to D4 was played Bishop to H3
King to D3 but now just the bishop to E6
we have Knight E5 sorry Knight the E5
and now King the E1 uh Knight to F3
check King to D1 and not Knight to D4 we
have Bishop to G8 and now Knights the B5
King to C1 and not Knight the C3 trying
to get that a king to D for uh Knight to
D5 setup so the pawn can be Advanced but
of course uh even this will not do any
anything Bishop H7 checking the D4
Bishop to G8 now comes Knight to D5 but
just King D2 and now after C4 Vincent
managed to advance that pawn but Maxim
just shows that there's no point in this
bishop captures King captures and he was
in this position on move 65 that Maxim
and Vincent agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here so it's a
pretty standard King and pawn end game
and of course you will not be able to
get that pawn to become a queen at some
point you will still meet the the white
king and of course everyone knows this
so yeah pretty pretty incredible stuff
one way uh I was watching the live
commentary uh in this position that
Vincent could have made it easier for
him is not to waste a Tempo with F5 he
could have played F6 and this would
allow him to at some point gain that
extra Tempo that he needs with the pawn
sort of the outmaneuver the light Square
bishop and the King but who would who
would think of this I mean you just push
F5 F4 F3 because you know the position
is winning uh you you just
didn't play it out to the Perfection and
then it ended in a draw but yeah
that's why Vincent uh took second place
he might have took taken second place
even if he won this game because then he
would go into a playoff against Magnus
Carlsen which would be very very intense
but he would definitely get a chance at
winning uh first place and defeated
World rapid Championship but yeah uh we
get Magnus in first Vincent in second
and of course Fabiano caruana who
defeated vladislavartame in the final
round uh in third place and as you've
seen in Blitz Magnus also won the blitz
section Hikaru Nakamura got second place
and uh well same amount of points uh
third place was hike martirosian so very
very incredible run by him as well but
yeah this is one of the games that I
really wanted to show you uh it was a
really intense and Magnus was watching
the game uh the entire time and I
believe exactly at this point where uh
Vincent messed it up
uh here after this uh he just Advanced
the pawn to F2 Magnus knew it was a
drawing you could see a huge huge smile
on his face knowing that he uh just
became the world rapid champion
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it I this will not this is
not my last video of 2022 I will release
another one and it will be a tricky
video it will not be a game but rather a
position for you to solve uh one that we
haven't uh covered before and a really
really weird one uh one that you will be
able to share with your friends at the
bar or the library you know I don't know
where you guys will be celebrating New
Year's uh so stay tuned uh for that as
well but yeah that's the game I really
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Adam Holt James Mayberry Luba milk
netkowski Michael hofst Consulting and
William Fuller for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you one of the
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the Chess World as usual we are
always looking for that first queen
sacrifice of 2023. so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day